تمت مداهمة منزلنا من قبل خمسة من
ضباط الشرطة بموجب المادة 12 من
قانون الإرهاب أثناء وجودهم هنا،
أخذوا هاتفي وهواتف أطفالي،
الأطفال آه الكمبيوتر المحمول المدرسي الذي تم
تدميره لكنهم كانوا يستخدمون على أي حال
مجموعة كاملة من أغراضنا الكهربائية
ثم شاهدوها  أنا أستخدم حرف L وشاهدني أرتدي
ملابسي،
لقد جمعوني في صندوق معدني في الجزء
الخلفي من فارفارو على الأرض لأنني لم أفعل ذلك،
لم أتمكن من الجلوس على المقاعد
CU أنا امرأة معاقة احتجزوني فيها
زنزانة لمدة 7 ساعات آه عندما حصلت أخيرًا على
مقابلتي، لقد تم توضيحي تمامًا
أنه يجب علي إدانة حماس، أنا لا أمزح، كان
ذلك في الأساس أنهم كانوا مثلك
ولم يكن الأمر حتى أشياءً.  قالوا إن
الأشياء التي قمت بإعادة نشرها كان لديهم
ملف كبير وكانوا
وكأنك أعادت نشر هذا وقلت هل
نعتقل أشخاصًا في المملكة المتحدة لإعادة نشر
أشياء وكانوا يقولون نعم، لقد
تم توضيح ذلك لي تمامًا  إذا
نددت بفلسطين إذا نددت
بتوماس فلن يتم اتهامي
ولكن من الواضح أنني لن أفعل ذلك
لذا سأراهم في المحكمة في مارس،
أفترض أن الله يبارك الديمقراطية العظيمة في
أه
المملكة المتحدة